police and protesters have clashed in
the thai capital bangkok during a
third straight day of anti-government
demonstrations
police used water cannons to try to
disperse the thousands
strong crowd advancing on them with riot
shields and
buttons the protesters who are defying a
ban on public gatherings
hit back with umbrellas and through
bottles they are calling for reforms to
the constitution and monarchy
as well as for the prime minister to
step down
well for more on this uh and the
situation on the street right now let's
bring in
philip sherwood from bangkok he's the
asia correspondent for the british
newspaper sunday times philip
we've seen police and protesters clash
what's the situation there right now
yeah those dramatic scenes were playing
out about an hour ago
uh the confrontation took about 30
minutes um
the at the situation right now is that
the protest leaders
encouraged the most of the crowd to
disperse they um
they were they had their umbrellas as
protection but they were up against
heavily
um equipped riot police and those water
cannon and the water cannon was
laced with blue ink and some sort of
chemical mix that was causing irritants
or
irritation to people's eyes and their
skin so the protest leaders
nearby university and remember many of
these protests are
students actually high school
difference in force we expect that they
will try and regroup again somewhere
tomorrow
they are clearly learning lessons from
hong kong protesters not just from the
use of umbrellas but from this idea of
sort of bait and switch on your
locations so um
we're hoping that you know for the
tonight's confrontation
has has finished but um it's not clear
if the police will try and go
looking for protesters in the university
they have blue
um some of them will have blue ink on
their skin now so you know they
they could be identified as having taken
part in tonight's events
well we're seeing live pictures from the
streets of bangkok
right now there are no confrontations as
far as
we can see uh on these pictures um
talk to us about the demands of the
protesters phillip
well these demands have um have morphed
and become much more far-reaching they
started earlier this year
with um just anger over the banning of a
progressive opposition party that was
popular with
um young people and students and which
was abandoned
rather contentious and controversial
circumstances by uh by the
constitutional court
but they have now um they've morphed
into a wider ranging political demands
there's anger that um that the
government that's in place now
is essentially led by the coup leader
from um
um 2014 and from other um um
and with other generals who took part in
the the last um the last coup
and so they're demanding a new
constitution they're demanding that
government steps down
but most contentiously and most
explosively they've added many of them
have added demands for reform to the um
royal family's role in thailand to uh to
their agenda they want to look at its
budget how it receives funds from
the government and they also want a
review of its of the political influence
of the king now
the royal family is a long venerated
institution here
uh loved by so many by many ties and
uh previously it's been considered
absolutely taboo to um to
raise questions about its role do you
think can the protesters hope to get
any of their demands met
it's it's a it's a tough tough ask i
mean they're up against
the um the the ruling establishment
which is the military-backed government
and the monarchy um they may have um
you know numbers in terms of uh you know
people on the street at the moment
but the government of uh chana chad the
prime minister the
former army chief has made clear that
there's only one place that they're
willing to maybe make some
concessions which is on some review to
the constitution but they've said even
that will be
a two-year process
but they have said that um he'd say said
today general prayer that he would not
be quitting
and they have made absolutely clear that
any questions about the
role of the royal family are um are off
limits and they've also made clear
they will uh prosecute people um who who
pursue this
philip sherwood thank you very much for
your reporting
from thailand